also the gunshots versus clicks when
danny is ranting and raving i wanted to
talk about that yeah well let's get into
that let's get into that so that was
another instance where we got into an
argument in the editing room i believe
both you guys wanted to put the gunshots
in how do you feel about it now 15. i
think it's
[ __ ] ridiculous
i absolutely 100 percent think that that
is one of the dumbest things we have
ever oh god i got to that's so hard i
was like that's so good why don't we do
showing anymore i think that was one
that was definitely an example of where
at first i remember being like i don't i
think this is so dumb and then charlie
winning me over and being like let me
just try it i'm like i don't think it's
gonna work
we left or whatever he put them all in
and i came in i was like okay he wins
that was so great and you were still in
the uh first of all it's not funny
secondly it's completely first you're
wrong it is funny it's not it's
hilarious no it isn't not so much the
gun firing but then the dry firing after
he's fired all the guns and it's just
clicking away it's great it's not